[Music]
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
ryan nicodemus is on vacation but don't
worry he's going to be joining us by
phone later in this episode and i'm here
with alabama hi everybody tk coleman is
here hey hey hey
welcome to the podcast show we got the
rest of our team in the studio as well
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we'll be joined by ryan
nicodemus and also later in the episode
for the lightning round we're joined by
youtuber and musician ruslan to argue
about well a few things we're going to
talk about judgment we're going to talk
about judgment as emotional clutter
we've got a great added value segment
for you as well a great listener tip and
so much more you can check out the full
three hour maximal edition of episode
356 where we answer four times the
questions and we dive deep into seven
different simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck alabama where would
you like to start today our first
question today is from danielle in
australia i'm currently a nanny to three
girls ages six to eight years old and
i'm wanting to implement an idea i
learnt from your podcast
that they can have control and can
choose how they react situations
and that they are the only ones who can
make themselves feel anything
whether it's happiness offense anger
sadness jealousy etc i'd love to hear
the experiences of those who are
successfully implementing this
and see what it would look and sound
like
so danielle i just yell at my daughter
and say only you can make yourself happy
only you can make yourself upset
how brilliant how dare you think i'm
upsetting you right now
you make me so mad when you think that
girl
[Laughter]
ryan you know what's fascinating is you
and i have been going down this road for
a while and it's it's something that
even as 40 year olds it's something
really hard to grasp because
i have built up this pattern of blaming
other people for my own
emotions my own emotional clutter and
here's what i'll say first off here
here's a a truth
that i want to unpack emotions are great
airplane passengers
but horrible pilots
and here's what i mean by that so
we we often think because what we're
saying here is like
well
anger only you can make yourself angry
you can make yourself upset and
therefore people think what i'm saying
is well it's bad to be angry you should
never want to be angry you should never
be angry
ryan you should never be upset that's
not what we're saying
what we're saying is this airplane is
full of emotions right but i don't want
to let them in the cockpit i don't want
my anger to steer me toward rage i don't
want my disappointment to steer me
toward judgment of someone else
right on you yeah
mr ryan come on man
oh i was just agreeing with josh i mean
if i was to say i would just say yeah
it's like so that's wonderful i love it
i think that's a great
sentiment for people to you know look at
when they're thinking about emotions uh
especially the negative ones right
because those are the ones that we act
out most with but how do you help a six
seven or eight year old
comprehend
uh
that that hey those emotions are really
nice passengers in your airplane
don't allow them to
fly your life but you know it's
interesting though josh because i you
don't yell it obviously that was a joke
earlier but this is the philosophy you
know that you live by so you're setting
this amazing you know uh example for
ella and she sees how you react to
different emotions and i think that's
really where it starts especially man
like with kids like when they're younger
so as infants
they can't comprehend anything so
they're just like you know little
emotional reaction machines and so it's
really up to us as the parent by the way
i have no kids so it's so easy for me to
give advice to parents but it's our job
you know as the parent
to uh
to to set that example for how we react
to our children's out of control
emotions and then eventually it gets to
a point where yeah i think probably six
seven eight year old is an appropriate
time to start helping uh these kids
unpack their emotions and help and talk
them through it hey why do you feel that
way
what what does it make you feel what
does that feeling make you want to do
doing that is that an appropriate
reaction like what if i reacted that way
and like really helping them unpack that
but going back to what i was saying in
the beginning
if the parent or the nanny in this case
hasn't set that example in the first six
or seven eight years
they're gonna have to start with
themselves first and that is when they
can uh you know start to maybe have that
conversation with those kids we also
often set the opposite example and
that's why ryan when i talk to you about
as 40 year olds we have all this baggage
we've we've carried on to that plane to
extend my metaphor and now mix metaphors
we're on that plane with all these
emotions and the reason that i often say
that person made me mad
is i want to assume the role
of the victim and it's not to say that
there isn't such thing as being
victimized i certainly have been
victimized but then how i respond to
that well quite often it has to do with
my cultural programming and i've been
programmed to blame blame blame blame
blame because in order for me to write
to be right someone else has to be
wrong they have to be incorrect but for
a kid
what we're often doing is we're showing
them how to blame other people and when
we show other people how to blame we
show kids how to blame other people then
they are going to pick up that baggage
and carry it onto the uh the airplane
with you
that's right yeah if the destination is
self-discovery
then our emotions can be our greatest
guide because then you can afford to
walk with them you can afford to sit
next to them talk with them spend some
time with them but the effort to try to
talk someone out of an emotion just
reinforces the idea that what you feel
is the problem but the feeling is never
the problem it's not the fact that
you're angry it's your anger plus the
idea that the best way to resolve this
anger is to punch you in the face
your jealousy is not the problem it's
the jealousy plus the best way to deal
with this jealousy is to steal your
stuff or to out compete you and so what
we do is what ryan said we talk our
children through
their fillings we treat their feelings
as if
it's worth giving our attention to in a
healthy way by saying hey man
why you so angry right now what are you
angry about we don't condemn them we
don't make them feel like our goal is to
get you to stop feeling as angry as soon
as possible right it's like what are you
angry about what is it about that that
makes you angry
yeah what does that make you want to do
and and the process of calming of
calming down usually it's an automatic
response from just having the
opportunity to be heard right and and
that's that's where we get the
opportunity to help our children learn
how to channel that emotional energy in
a constructive direction because
as
as it's often been said emotion is just
energy in motion and it's the way in
which we direct it that determines the
result
yeah
yeah it's interesting i was uh
when we were in australia josh we're
getting on a qantas flight
and um i'll never fly them again
uh i'm sure other people have had lovely
experiences with them but i have not but
a long story short i was talking to the
gate agent and i had a complaint and i
was being real nice and courteous and i
said man i said it must be tough
having to um
deal with all these customer complaints
and she said to me she goes well
you know each customer gets to decide
how they react
and i thought well she's not wrong there
like that's a pretty
pretty uh pretty good observation so i
mean really yeah i mean if i just you
know a pity answer to give to this i
would you know i'd say something along
the lines of uh
you know we can't control our emotions
we can control only how we react to them
yeah if i were to pin that at all i
would simply talk about the judgments
that we make based on those emotions
we're gonna be talking to the youtuber
and musician ruslan later and
he
well
he
made a video about the minimalists and
our judgments of other people and at the
time what did i want to do i wanted to
judge him back and what i realized here
is oh no this isn't
an opportunity for me to judge him it's
an opportunity for me to better
understand him so i invited him to come
on the podcast and we had a loving
disagreeing strongly disagreeing
conversation but we did so in a way that
i felt was productive and if we if we
map that on to our children
okay
the questions tk is asking about
well tell me about that anger tell me
about that sadness tell me about why
you're upset and as soon as they start
steering it toward blame okay why is
that person responsible and helping them
understand not through telling not
through instructing not through being
didactic
but through questioning exploring
together all of a sudden it opens up the
world that's what makes room for love
because we can look at judgment and we
can say oh yeah you're acting angrily so
you're lashing out you're blaming
someone else you're judging them for
their behavior and you're saying that's
who that person is that person always
makes me mad that person always makes me
upset that person always makes me cry
okay these things might be true
technically but ultimately how we're
responding to that person
is
well how we're responding to them allows
us opens up the the world of of
possibilities to stop being upset to
move away from that upset into that
place of understanding
imagine this oh i'm sorry go ahead oh
yeah no i was just gonna say and
speaking of judgment there was a poll on
twitter where our audience judged our
hair i don't want to talk about the
results
oh he would he would there were there
were some very clear judgments on that
poll i just i just want to say ryan
there's a whole stack of ballots that
that are missing in arizona
[Laughter]
you know what i was going to do today
because
because you're not in
[Laughter]
because you're not in the studio i we
used to have that cardboard cut out of
us we that tour that got canceled back
in 2020 for some reason why did we
cancel tours in 2020
anyway um we had a cardboard cutout of
us we were sending to each city and
people were going to take photos and
like at prominent landmarks
and uh we unfortunately we decluttered
that we didn't amass it we trashed it
and
i was going to have a cardboard cutout
of you here in the studio because
yeah the people on the patreon live
stream have been really brutal they're
like you guys can't even get ryan to
phone it in
and now literally he's phoning it in
dk you want to have the last word on
this question
all right i was just going to say
imagine that it were somehow possible
for you to
uh reach adulthood without anyone having
taught you what your sensation of hunger
meant
and you felt hungry what would you do
first you'd experience that pain
discomfort tension whatever you call it
that we use the label hunger to describe
and because you wouldn't know what
hunger was for you might just react in a
bunch of unhealthy ways you might bang
your head against a wall you might start
yelling at people screaming at them you
might start running around hoping that
the filling goes away you might try to
ignore it you might grab the first thing
that you can find and try to eat it even
if it's poison ivy
if you don't know what a thing is for
then abuse will be inevitable right but
the problem isn't hunger
your sensation of hunger is a good thing
that's there to help you survive and
thrive but you need to be taught what
it's there for it's the same with our
feelings whether it's anger sadness all
of those emotions have something to
teach us and just like hunger if no one
shows us what it's for then we're bound
to react and respond to that in a way
that's self-destructive but once you
show someone hey look that sensation you
feel that's part of what it means to be
alive here's the healthy response to
have when you feel it because there are
things you can do in response to that
sensation that might harm you but here
are the options that you have for what's
healthy what's constructive
that's beautiful
right right i'm so glad tk's with us
likewise ryan's going to stick around
for a few more questions on the private
podcast danielle thank you for your
question i'm going to send you a copy of
our first film it's called minimalism a
documentary about the important things
you can find it at
minimalismfilm.com we recently removed
it from netflix and it's available with
six hours six hours and danielle will
send you the six hours of bonus
interviews as well beautiful film 79
minutes but we had all these other
interviews and not all of them could
make the film so you can find it over at
minimalismfilm.com you can also check it
out on itunes or amazon where you can
rent it or purchase it as well but
danielle we'll send you a copy of that
really it's um it's a story
that
well you know it's a there's several
different stories that interweave this
whole thing and here's one thing i
realized ryan while i've got you on the
phone is quite often we get angry at
someone it's usually through a screen it
makes it really easy to get angry if
there's a screen between us meaning
you're a thousand miles away a hundred
miles away or on the other side of town
you're texting me and you're not
responding the way i want you to respond
but when we were right here that's why i
had ruslan on later in the episode you
realize
when you hug someone it breaks down all
the barriers and you see so many hugs in
that first film
because what we were doing we were out
on the road and we still do this now i
met someone at a coffee shop yesterday
he said oh my god you're
that one guy from the minimalists and i
said give me a hug man he goes oh that
would be so nice
and
we're starved for that and so we can
disagree
but we can also
hug it out before and after you'll see a
lot of that in
our first documentary minimalism
minimalismfilm.com
man i almost want to say
that six hours of of extended footage is
better than the movie itself
it allows you to do so much there's so
much good there's so many good
interviews in that it's amazing yeah
yeah i mean matt did a just a brilliant
job weaving it all together but if you
want to dive deeper you can certainly
find it over at minimalismfilm.com
so it is time for our lightning round
this is where we answer your text
messages you can text your questions at
937-202-4654
now ruslan during the lightning round
this is where we do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response okay but not
really we just ramble on a bit and
eventually podcast sean he uh he tweezes
out something pithy we call them minimal
maxims which we can share in the show
notes so during this lightning round
we're going to disagree a bit but i'm
hoping that we can disagree in a way
where we end up finding common ground
our lightning round question today is
from mike
what ways have you dealt with judgment
from people close to you and your family
it always feels like the closer the
person the harder to handle
that sounds true to me but
if someone i don't know is down the
street judging me right now i
i don't think anything of it right but
if tk has some sort of judgment about me
i'm gonna pause and so the reason i
thought this question was appropriate
and my pithy answer to the question is
judgment is a mirror that reflects the
insecurities of the judge
and ruslan you made a video recently
about kendrick kendrick lamar's new
album
and
i left that comment
and you made a video responding to it
about judgment
and i think there was a misunderstanding
there and i want to apologize first off
because
the
there was a lack of clarity there
because i wasn't saying that judgment is
bad i was simply making a statement
about judgment it is true that i make
judgments every day of my life right
um but whenever i'm making a judgment
about tk or about my wife
i'm reflecting i'm holding up a mirror
and looking at my own insecurities about
that situation so i'm trying to figure
out where where do we disagree there
so you said when your judgment is a
mirror
of your own insecurities yeah that yeah
reflects the insecurities of the judge
which if i'm judging that i'm the judge
in that scenario yes yes so i think i
would disagree in the sense that if my
wife tells me
hey bud
you're gaining a little weight
and you're getting a little uh
getting a little muffin top there
and we value fitness
and i've been hitting my you know my
wife's going through this whole fitness
thing she's crushing it right now and
she's doing really well
so if she's holding me accountable she's
judging me she's like dude like you
can't have cookies at night like you
know you're not having sugar like
i don't think that's a insecurity of her
i actually think that that judgment
which may sting in the moment and it may
tell me i have to delay gratification or
i have to not eat what i want to eat it
may sting it may be like oh that's that
doesn't feel good but i actually believe
it's coming from a good and sincere
place
to hold me accountable to the very same
things that i said i value it sounds
like what you're saying that judgment is
really
the application of critical thought to
any situation i would say so yeah it's
evaluating it's not necessarily
expressing an insecurity all right yeah
and so
tk you and i have had these discussions
previously about the difference between
description and prescription maybe you
can talk to me a bit about that yeah so
description is when you simply give an
account or an explanation for what
something is right if i say working out
is when you push yourself outside of a
comfort zone in order to develop
strength or endurance a prescription is
when i make a claim about what you
should or shouldn't do there's kind of a
value judgment if i give a description
of working out i'm not saying that you
should or shouldn't do it i may think
working out is bad i may think working
out is good but i'm just giving a
description
and it's the impression i got when you
made this statement about judging is
that you were giving a description of
what you think judgment is that's right
you weren't giving a prescription saying
hey
therefore no one should judge because
you admit that's something that i do and
it's also a necessary part of life yeah
that that's what jesus said not me but
um the thing that's fascinating here
between because i i am not telling
there's no prescription here i'm trying
to describe a particular truth
and i feel that ruslan what what i saw
in your video is maybe just a
misunderstanding of what i was trying to
communicate and that's why i apologize
because i was simply trying to describe
that judgment is a mirror but i wasn't
trying to
judge you specifically
so i think that's where we may disagree
i think we're all giving prescriptions
all the time i just i don't think that
we're sober enough about it i think what
you guys have done has been an amazing
prescription for my life right i mean
everything about getting rid of tennis
shoes like i've minimalized my tennis
shoes i've minimalized the amount of
clothes i have i've minimal all these
different things have been as
prescriptions i don't know if anyone
grabs a non-fiction book or turns on a
documentary like minimalism and goes
i'm just going to watch this with some
popcorn and not care about any of the
implications this has for my personal
life i think people are looking for
answers and looking for prescriptions
yeah i want to get to the essence of it
because i think sometimes we're saying
something
and we
we're using the same language but we
mean something different when i talk
about prescriptions i think they can be
really helpful
in the sense of something that's
mechanical if you need to fix your bike
or repair your car and you break out a
manual that's a prescription on how to
repair the car right
when it goes beyond
the mechanical is i think when we often
get
well we get stuck because
the instead of prescribing the actions
what we try to do with the minimalists
is help people understand the essence of
the problem
and through understanding the problem
the how-to begins to take care of itself
but what is much more powerful is having
that deeper understanding of
oh this is the actual problem because
quite often we're talking about
the solutions the solutions become
another problem because
discipline or motivation isn't there we
think oh well i'm just never going to do
it of course you're going to do it
though if you really understand the
weight the gravity of the problem
why
versus what and how yes that's what
that's the difference i think so yes i
like that i think it's important also to
make a distinction between judging the
person and judging the process i can say
hey your process isn't efficient or if
this is your goal you're following a
process that's not going to lead you
there and we can evaluate a process
without saying you are unworthy to exist
or you are a horrible person for getting
something having to do with the process
wrong and i think when discussions on
judgment come up
there are two things that produce
tension on one side the person who's
issuing the prescription it can be easy
for them to maybe judge the person
because there are inefficiencies in the
process
that's also true for the person who's
listening sometimes if you're listening
to someone criticize your process it can
be easy to take that personally even
when it's not sometimes judgment is just
critical thinking but sometimes judgment
is a mirror reflecting back the
insecurities of the person sometimes
it's it's just not an automatic thing
we have a little segment on the podcast
we call more about less or we read
something as a jump off point sometimes
it's an article or a tweet so i brought
in
this
article from
scarymommy.com
my favorite dating site
hey i'm gonna get a gk chesterton quote
in before we before you quote eckhart
tolle um to so we can keep our
priorities in order but anyway this is
probably because we're all pronouncing
his name three different ways i think
it's eckhart tolle right i thought i
thought
okay then on the odd man out i said i
should verify it but i say
so okay
thankfully there is no right or wrong so
we're good
the gk cool and this captures kind of
where i stand on like the the beliefs
the opinions the good bad he says the
purpose of an open mind is that of an
open mouth and it is to chew up on
something solid
an old philosophy professor of mine
timothy mcgrew he used to always say
keep an act of mind rather than a
passive mind and i tend to like that a
little bit better than open or closed
because
i'm not open to everything yep and i'm
not close to everything but i choose to
be active about it all i choose to think
critically and creatively about it all
but at the end of the day i want to
close my mouth and my mind on something
substantial and chew on it yeah you
don't want it to be porous
so let me get to this article here i'm
just going to read a few of them and
maybe we can agree or we can disagree on
them i'd like that too so this is a 100
plus eckhart tolle
tolle slash toll quotes that will
seriously enlighten you which is a bit
uh a bit hyperbolic there i'm not gonna
read the whole article we'll put a link
to it in the show notes but here are a
few of the quotes we'll start with the
first one here the past has no power
over the present
well tk you and i often say you talked
to me about this you've never said it on
the podcast but how any of these little
minimal maxims these little profundities
these bromides that we toss about they
can be simultaneously true and radically
untrue at the same time yeah i believe
that every statement no matter how much
you love it no matter how logical it is
can be made to sound absolutely
ridiculous if you easily interpret it in
a certain way one day we should do a
test where i can prove this you give me
any statement and i can show you how
someone can interpret that in a way that
makes it sound ridiculous let's do it
right now
is just put it on twitter and 20 people
will show you
all right so the past
has no power over the present moment
well in every day practical life that's
certainly not true yeah because we stay
stuck in the past now of course the past
exists only in the present moment
because there is no past in that respect
and i'm sure that's what he means so
right that's where we have to get
curious right what does he mean
because if i went up to eckhart tolle i
was like well that's stupid because i i
have a cousin who's still living in the
past today is eckhart tolle gonna go oh
bro you blew my mind
i never thought about that he'll
probably say yeah i know people too who
are in some meaningful sense stuck in
the past but let's go a little bit
deeper rousseau here's another one for
you some changes look negative on the
surface but you will soon realize that
space is being created in your life for
something new to emerge well it seems
like a a bit on the uh
a new take on that chinese farmer
parable in a way yeah sometimes the
worst things that happen to us the worst
suffering sure ends up being the thing
we're most grateful for yeah that's
that's i like that quote it's a good
quote
so no discipline seems uh
uh
enjoyable in the moment but then it
leads to a harvest as a new testament
old testament i think that's in um
i think that's in proverbs yeah so yeah
that's
he's copying the bible
[Laughter]
let's jump around here so
uh let's see sometimes letting things go
is an act of far greater power than
defending or hanging on
well as the minimalist is probably not
the only one that thinks these are just
like all super fake deep quotes like the
skin is the skin until the skin leaves
its body and then it is no longer one
with the skin like well so
i'll play angel's advocate with that
we call those faux funded ease where
someone's both under these yeah i'm
going to use that it sounds profound at
first and then you listen again and
you're like whoa you just
that doesn't make any sense
uh my daughter makes these up all the
time she has a great twitter account
it's not her account but we just like
tweet the craziest [ __ ] that she says
and uh yeah and she's full of of faux
fun that is she looked at me uh earlier
this year and she goes is the 4th of
july on the 4th of july this year
so angel's advocate first a full funded
is something that actually has no
meaning you're pretending to be saying
something it has no meaning that's not
the the concern or criticism here and i
hear this comes up a lot which is why i
want to play angel's advocate with it
the concern here is like okay i get what
the brother's saying
but does it even need to be said right
it's like so basic and so obvious
i get that
but i also work with elementary school
students and high school students and
one of the things they have taught me
and they continue to teach me is that
obviousness
is relative to the hearer right because
when when we listen to something we go
okay does that even need to be said
we're bringing a whole lot of life
experience and a whole lot of
accumulated wisdom into the moment and
so when someone says hey man sometimes
working hard is a good thing it sounds
laughably obvious but believe it or not
just like there are people every year
who are born who need to be taught how
to pronounce the words of the alphabet
there are thousands of people out there
millions of people who will hear that
for the first time today and they'll go
wow
that's really profound and some people
will hear it just because it came from
you or just because it came from their
brother and so we can never say the
obvious truths too much because as angry
as someone will get on twitter for you
daring to say something that they
already knew god forbid there are always
people out there who don't know it and
who need to hear it from you so i am a
defender of stating obvious truths to
every generation because there are
people born every day for whom those
truths aren't obvious if it's true
say it i love that let me just let me
just add something to this and this is
this may be controversial and yeah
you guys may not like me for this but
i think
the deeper issue in my opinion is that
there's the spectrum between
post-modernism where there is no
objective reality and everything is your
truth versus my truth and your reality
and then there's the other end of the
spectrum of like radical fundamentalism
from a religious mindset and i think
i would say jesus and the scriptures are
going to lean more towards hey there's
objective reality there's absolute truth
there's morals there's right and wrong
and i think the issue with someone like
like an eckhart tolle is that he's
taking ancient truths that we've known
like you said the thing i was like oh
yeah that that's a proverb right and and
it's being repackaged to a postmodern
world where people don't want objective
prescriptions they don't want objective
realities they don't want to be told
what is right and wrong they want to
live their truth in their reality and i
think that to me is the deeper
underlying issue of why he's even so
popular of how kendrick goes from i'm
baptized i'm going to church i'm trying
to marry my my kid's mother
to foe realities what would you call
them go fundamentally full funded these
uh i'm gonna kind of weasel my way out
of whatever i don't really feel like
doing in the moment because it's not
conducive to how i feel about my reality
and so again i don't mean to get super
controversial but this super duper
post-modern you are your truth whatever
you feel is real
flesh that out to its logical conclusion
and some of the stuff that's happening
in society right now and there's some
wonky stuff happening
based on this whatever you whatever
floats your boat bro just do you and
your truth and so i think that's the the
the deeper issue with the new ageism and
why why is eckhart all of a sudden an
authority oh it's because people really
don't want to deal with some of the
objective ancient truths we've had all
along in my opinion we got so much more
to talk about in alabama including a
bunch of simple living segments but
first what do you got for us here's a
minimalist insight from one of our
listeners
hi my name is stephanie i'm calling from
michigan and i'm calling with a comment
for
two maybe three suggestions the first
one is there's a website in an app
called think dirty where it will list
ingredients of makeup and kind of give a
clean score based on their chemicals and
everything that's inside them
so if you're looking for a clean
alternative you can scan makeup products
that you already have and
kind of either score if you're looking
for more
better alternatives with any better
ingredients they'll give you
alternatives listed and then you can
actually shop right from their app as
well
my second suggestion would also be
called good on you
um it's where they list
ecologically responsible and animal
friendly
alternative to makeup and clothing so
you can search on their website if
you're looking for you know lipstick
primer foundation everything like that
and my third suggestion would be my own
little personal rule is i typically have
one quality makeup item for each you
know specific area so if i'm looking for
eyeliner i have one quality eyeliner i'm
looking for mascara i have one
vascular tube at a time so this helps to
cut down on my makeup that way i don't
have you know 17 different eyelash
eyeshadow palettes as well all right
before we get to our added value segment
this week let's say big thanks for ryan
interrupting his vacation to call in
today and also thanks to ruslan for
joining us today you can check out his
youtube channel we'll put a link to that
in the show notes real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
if you enjoy our podcast
and you want some other questions
answered about relationships or
parenting or sex or wellness my wife bex
has a podcast which i co-host with her
it's called how to love you can find it
on
apple podcast or spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts it's called how to
love we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well for our added value
this week since we argued quite a bit on
the private podcast with ruslan and it
was the argument stemmed from kendrick
lamar's new album which is called mr
morale and the big steppers i thought i
played my favorite song from
that album
this is rich spirit now this is my
favorite kendrick album and i really
like
good kid mad city or like damn but there
was something about this where there's
this man who is
clinging to his ego as it slips through
his hands and the holder that the
tighter he holds onto it the more it
seems to slip away and i think you'll
certainly see that in this song
he's becoming enlightened
but doing so he's grasping to sort of
to not be enlightened
and you're seeing the dichotomy of both
enjoy rich spirit by the way we got a
bunch more surprise questions on the
private podcast this week like
how do you tell a narcissist to stop
giving you gifts
under what circumstances does it make
sense to go into debt
what is one possession that you'd be
better off without plus seven different
simple living segments and a million
more questions and if you want to hear
all that check out the minimalists
private podcast visit
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play and your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
immediate access to all of our archives
recordings of live events weekly home
tours and our private community of
thousands of minimizers like you if you
have a question or comment for our
podcast give us a call 406-219-7839
or email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com you can follow the
minimalists on tik-tok instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalists
to get our podcast show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus t.k coleman alabama podcast
sean jordan no more professor sean
social jess danny unknown
post-production peter m of the immigrant
and the rest of our team i'm joshua
fields milburn if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
[Music]
love people
and use things
because the opposite never
works
thanks for listening yo we'll see you
next time
peace
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
everybody